in the migrant camps in northern France
it's Mother Nature that calls the shots
many here are waiting to catch small
boats to the UK
today it was the weather which disrupted
those Crossings not an announcement from
Westminster
is they like most people we met was
unaware of the planned Crackdown his
wife is sick with cancer in the UK
he'll get to her any way possible
if you go on the boat you could die if
you get caught in the UK you could get
deported and never go back will you
still try
yes why because he's been
fed up I'm enough how long been separate
my five my wife my son how long I've
been separate I'm being ten years
the perilous Channel Crossings are often
the final leg of a long journey many
have fled War some have been abused and
beaten
but like 19 year old Afghan Jabba they
won't give up on their UK dreams
if they send us away we'll come back he
says and if they send me to Rwanda I
haven't committed a crime so I'll come
back
and today the criminal gangs controlling
this Shoreline seemed undeterred as we
filmed we heard deals for future
Crossings
breaking the traffickers grip here won't
be easy Smugglers earn hundreds of
thousands of pounds controlling this
route one told us even if people were
sent to the Amazon they keep on trying
to get to the UK charity workers fear
tougher rules in the UK could make
Crossings riskier
I think there's a very good chance they
could get more dangerous people are
going to want to take risky routes to
try and go hidden and then there's going
to be high levels of exploitation when
they get to the UK because they're going
to be pushed underground in the UK
though many people feel like they've had
enough that the systems being abused
what's your response to that
unfortunately what the British public
have heard is not the truth and a lot of
the anger I understand but it's
misdirected because of misinformation
here the desperation feeds determination
and without more safe routes Smugglers
will keep on risking people's lives
Siobhan Robbins Sky News northern France